hey 42 here have you ever had a burning
question which you've always wanted
answered or you've never known where to
turn or who to ask well now it's your
chance to get it answered once and for
all I'm so excited to finally be able to
announce my shiny new websites 42 comm
it's a fantastic way to keep up with my
latest uploads and read the full
transcripts of all my videos it's the
first place on the internet along with
YouTube that you will find my new videos
as soon as they are released but most
importantly you can go to 42 comm and
ask me any question for example why is
the sky blue or how are black holes
formed it can be about science maths
history entertainment life style or
simply general knowledge pretty much no
topic is off-limits
once you've posted your question anyone
can vote it or you can also vote up
other people's questions if you think
they should be answered every week the
questions does have gained the most up
votes or if I just see a question which
I think you guys will find really
interesting I will answer it with a
video right here on YouTube for everyone
to see my goal of these videos is to
answer your questions in the simplest
way possible so everyone can understand
it but at the same time keeping it
concise and entertaining so be sure to
visit 40 to calm and check it out the
website will constantly be evolving with
more features being added so you guys
can get more and more out of it as time
goes on I really hope it can be a place
for the 42 community to come together
and make 42 better and more enjoyable
for everyone
[Music]